I'm Jim and this is "One Day Build".
With "The Guardians Of The Galaxy" movie coming out,
I thought it would be fun to build a Star Lord mask,
Kind of staying in the theme of it being cheap and easy materials you can find,
Everything you can find at... Like, your local dollar store, hardware store, hobby shop...
I'm gonna go over some of the core materials that we're gonna use,
And then we'll just start building and see what happens.
All right, well these are some of the materials that we're gonna use.
These are our base, kind of core materials.
The materials you might use might vary a little bit, but the base... for this whole thing,
Is going to be this Iron Man mask.
Now I actually found this at a Five Below,
Which is kind of like a dollar store, but everything's five bucks or less.
This was like four/five dollars... There was like, a bin of them, I bought a bunch of them.
I went to a dollar store, found this child's helmet.
This will actually be like... The back of the helmet,
And I think we'll probably use this for the eyes and stuff.
Other parts are just gonna be kind of random, PVC pieces, bits of plastic,
Aluminium tubing, I usually keep a bin of just kind of miscellaneous parts.
You can go to the hardware store and buy some of these pieces.
I guess that I'm not 100% sure what I'm gonna use yet,
But some various, pieces of PVC tubing and different cool-looking fittings and stuff.
Also, I want the eyes to light up in the mask, kind of like it does in the movie,
Without getting too complicated.
So again at a dollar store, I went, bought this child's bracelet,
Yeah it's cool, lights up. It's like fifty cents or something.
Well, probably the biggest helper here, kind of tool box, is, what I use, is plastic weld.
It's a two-part epoxy putty,
Like a plumber's putty, but when you wet your hands,
It actually becomes really easy, kind of, you can manipulate it a little bit easier,
Last a little bit longer and you can smooth it really nice with your fingers.
Let's just start building and see what happens.
All right...
All right, so it's coming along,
It's... You can see it's, kind of starting to take shape now...
I just kinda glued these with the hot glue gun...
Just sort of temporarily, just to see how it kind of all looks before I apply any adhesive,
Or putty in any of the other spots there.
But, um...
Yeah, that's... You can see it's starting to look a little similar.
I'm just gonna use these aluminium tubes.
I can find these at basically any hobby store,
Hobby Lobby or Michael's or any model building store,
Generally can usually get a package of them,
in various diameters and lengths.
Or you can buy them individually.
Pretty inexpensive, they're easy to cut and...
Yeah, I mean, they're great for having a little piping and tubing and stuff come out.
Should work great... Oh, the other piping,
You can also probably use aluminium wire
to line all the elements and stuff like that, will probably work just as good.
But yeah, that's it so far...
Keep, you know, plugging along.
I think next we're gonna cut the kid's helmet and add that to the back of the helmet and kind of tie it all in.
Yeah...
All right well, after about ten hours of work this is what we we're left with:
The Star Lord mask,
All in all, turned out pretty well, I thought...
It looks pretty close to the one that's in the movie,
Considering we started off with this, yeah, and wound up with this, not too bad.
A few things I would have liked to have done, would have liked to finish some of the detailing on
the back of the helmet, it just didn't happen...
And then I kind of cheated in some of the areas like the...
I just glued some metallic wall anchors for the detailing there,
And the face plate, actually, I never sculpted, it's just a piece of plastic that I cut into the shape and
Covered with aluminium tape, and then kind of penned in the details.
But actually, that worked pretty good...
Can turn the lights on here.
It actually fits pretty good, fits pretty snug...
And...
Yeah...
That's it, you... You too can be Star Lord
If you want to do it for Halloween or a cosplay or something, hopefully you found this...
Helpful, or entertaining...
But... Yeah, you can go out and make your own or, probably wait a couple of weeks and buy one in, like, a toy store.
I'm sure it won't be long before there'll be Star Lord masks and...
All the costume shops and toy stores, but...
But if you're like me and you'd rather build your own...
Yeah, hopefully, like I said you found this somewhat helpful.
If so, go ahead and leave me a comment, and yeah,
Until next time, good luck saving the galaxy, I'm gonna go home and get some sleep.